hello everybody my name is markiplier
and oh market player yeah that's me
anyway welcome to let's play labyrinth
now this is a small indie horror game
made by always alpha games and it's it's
tiny it's a tiny thing so but I think it
promises to be a little bit of an
interesting experience so oh my okay
umm yes only way it's basically designed
to be like a maze or something basically
the objective I saw in the description
was a game with lots of corners and lots
of monsters so I don't know let's let's
find out okay yeah I really don't know
what to expect in this game other than
that it is just a labyrinth
I believe it's randomly generated
hallways but I'm not sure now I really
don't know what to expect so I'm kind of
apprehensive about what's going on I
mean no weapons obviously just walking
down hallways to no avail I don't even
know if there's an exit
okay all right
Oh long hallway I okay all right even
yeah I found it won't is perusing oh boy
oh don't make me have a choice left eeny
Meeny I'll go this way
oh now this is how horror games should
be
starts off with not knowing anything
having no idea what to expect and just
dropping you in the situation whoa what
the hell what the hell
methinks there is a graphical error here
exit okey dokey oh my oh lordy there's
not an exit
that's heads heads it's very strange
it's getting whiter am i leaving well
I'm confused I'd escaped the labyrinth
what I think that might have been a
little too easy
uh Tony pang yeah ah maybe you should
reevaluate your labyrinth alright I'm
gonna go in monster mouths I didn't even
see anything okay
yeah right then yeah I did yeah I'm the
best I'm the best there ever was you're
welcome friend oh I'm gonna take another
crack at this alright we're back in we
are back in the game
holy crap that took a little bit longer
than I had hoped for anyway yeah
obviously it's a beta game small indie
world
and so it may take some finagling to get
to work but anyway we're back in and I'm
going to avoid the eggs at this time if
I see it I'm going to turn around go the
other way so anyway we are back in the
labyrinth I mean I won't knock the
studio or the person who made it at all
because you know some bugs are to be
experienced but if you are trying to
play this game and the download link is
in the description below if you're
trying to play this game um try it in
Windows XP compatibility mode service
pack 2 and wait a little bit at the
loading screen when you first come up to
the screen
wait about I don't know 10 seconds or so
before you do anything and another
choice I'll try right this time I
actually have no idea how long well I
haven't seen anything yet and I didn't
see any monsters in the first place for
yourself that sounds familiar I remember
that my whole buddy Billy screaming in
the background
Billy so crazy Oh Billy's great at
parties yeah the suspense is killing me
he just knows something's gonna pop up
around the corner
hello is anybody there man nothing's
happening
I'm just kind of making me very worried
and they get all these choices here whoo
I just have a feeling it like some
screaming up behind me
probably nothing is but you know I think
there might be something there I just
have all these experiences with other
games where things creep up behind me
when I'm unsuspectingly like the
Slenderman is gonna come up and rape me
in the button and I god what is that
my god
I can sprint I didn't know good but good
lord in lieu hi Devin what was that
thing I don't know why but I'm going
back to look what it was good god that
was the most disturbing thing I've ever
seen oh I mean good god that was the
freakiest thing I mean I've seen a lot
of freaky things but good Lou no good
lord I mean my god that thing that sing
I don't know what that thing is but that
thing
hmm that's probably what the Slenderman
looks like without his suit on oh god
man all right let's go another way
mother of god what is this thing I swear
I don't wanna die Oh oh god they're
gonna box me in they're gonna box man
they do it live either good about you
oh there's three of them now jeez and
why is everything turned red come on oh
oh this is such baloney
oh good oh you got a weird like face
vagina I don't know oh no no I'm boxed
in I got nowhere to go I got nowhere to
run
I'm trapped I'm trapped I didn't know
where to go
I've already been down there and just
did him I'm gonna die I'm gonna die and
there's like no Auto healing soma hey
next hit I get a brother died good to go
ah okay all right just kill me just kill
me kill me oh what's that you stuck on
the wall all that hits so stuck for you
I'm gonna go Raghu yeah I made it
ah everything really really red now I
can't see I can't see for [ __ ]
oh god I'm gonna run I'm just gonna run
for it though say they can't get me I
won't see a monster coming up out front
of nowhere I'm so dead oh hello what's
this oh is this the exit no it's not
that it's just some weird graphical
error again huh I can't see anything oh
it's another one just kill me man don't
look at me oh you can't see me
you don't know he doesn't know shut up
he doesn't know guys just shut up just
shut up and be cool graphical error shut
up and be cool the anklet I said I
wasn't gonna find the exit
but I mean come on I'm going to the exit
god Wow let's see what happens if they
kill me I don't know what's gonna happen
let's just let him kill me you've
already seen the exit kill me my body's
ready where'd you go where'd you go did
he go where did he go I can't see uh-oh
hey is that a couple of them that's a
couple of them isn't it hey buddy hey
friend oh you wanna hi aah
Oh huh Technicolor okay look before you
turn the corner I don't need to look
he's very obvious he's exceptionally
obvious oh man good press any key to
continue
I don't want to continue I think I've
had enough Oh
all right that's enough for me
yeah that's enough that's not enough is
it it's never enough all right I'll take
one more try at it but I've already seen
you getting big crashes and I hope it
didn't crash all right that's all I can
hope you can crash again that thing is
like a freakiest thing I've ever seen in
my entire life okay I think that might
be the only monster but the thing said
monster models so maybe there's another
thing in here
I don't know if you guys want to try for
yourself the links in the description
below
yes I am is pretty cool
I mean jiminy cheese those things I
don't know I don't even know I don't
know if they like appear just like
farther in the maze but after I got a
certain distance they popped up
everywhere whoo man if I'd have known
that thing was lurking on early on I
wouldn't have been so brazen about just
jumping around this place I mean I knew
something was gonna happen but I didn't
know that was gonna happen
lot more dead ends than before okay
they're about to pop up they're coming
double dead end what what doesn't even
make sense
that's impossible
alrighty then I actually don't know how
long I've been playing for because my
timer ran over a bit hmm
I'm gonna call this thing this big naked
Slenderman
either they're not as um you know they
don't like I think I need to go this way
no that's a dead end edge maybe I just
got a map spawn with it multiple dead
ends I don't know yeah they're not
they're not good enough to be called
Slenderman self they're just tall ski
and my buddy Hayes built boo Oh Billy
where is the graph Claire that points
towards the exit it's awfully convenient
how that does that anyway we're the
monsters you're supposed to be around
here somewhere any second now hmm we're
gonna bump up around a corner any second
now guys she's only around a corner any
second now
yeah I swear those things are the
freakiest things I've ever seen in my
life I mean my god they remind me of the
shamblers from quake does anybody
remember the shamblers course you
remember the shamless another most
hideously Horrors rific thing in school
God boy didn't walk I mean good easy oh
my god oh god that was on I saw it I saw
it's like leg around that corner what am
I going towards it hello Seimei alright
just kill me
cover my body is ready Oh was that
uh-huh can't make it around the corner
let's get a good look
I was freaky he's got like was like
flaps of skin over his arm like winged
long dangly fingers and this weird face
vagina I don't know the human feet he's
got perfectly normal feet I don't know
he's so freaky alright I'm out of time
yes please did murder me fertilize me
thank you thank you alright
those three of them oh there was three
of them I didn't not know them
oh god this games games a little
terrifying and he's pretty good pretty
well made I mean well I mean it's the
best you can do when you just program
your own game from the ground up but
seriously house I was pretty good they
got me good I had no idea what to expect
I really didn't and when I first saw
that monster really good I was kind of
discouraged by the crashing but if you
want to get it to work here's my advice
and if you're asking me later how did
you get to work this out get it to work
so you know come on I'll give you the
best I can
um run it in cobalt ability mode for
windows xp service pack 2 and wait about
10 seconds on the splat this screen here
wait 10 seconds here so if you're coming
back to me and being like yeah it's game
to work um this is how you get the game
to work art
I'm out of time thank you so much for
watching let me know what you think of a
game in the description below and if you
play it you know let me know if you
played what you think of it anyway thank
you so much watching click the links in
there just click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye